سعيد عريس فلسطين ارتقى شهيدا هذا ما
تردده الام المكلومه لم تمهل الصواريخ
الاسرائيليه فلذه كبدها سعيد الذي لم يمضي
على زواجه الا اسابيع معدوده في غزه ام
سعيد تقيم في المانيا منذ عقدين تضاعفت
اوجاعها اذ صارت كله
ومكلومة يعني بعدين ها ب 7 اكتوبر اجت
الاحداث وبعد ما اجت الاحداث ما كان هو في
بيته خاف من اجت اليهود قربت عند المينا
هو ساكن عند المينا في غزه ف راح هاجر
لمكان ثاني رحل لمكان ثاني فلما راح لمكان
ثاني اجت الطائرات وقصفت مسجد دار السلام
ببرلين واحد من المؤسسات التي تقدم خدمات
ومراسم العزاء للعائلات الفلسطين في
المانيا ارتفع عدد المراسم العزاء التي
تقام في المسجد او في البيوتات او في
النوادي بشكل رهيب جدا اكتشفنا ان هناك
جالعه غزويه كبيره الان احيانا هناك ثلاثه
اربعه مراسم عزاء احيانا اكثر اقل القران
الحكيم حزن ودموع في مقر منتدى المنطار
الذي هو جمعيه اسسها مثق غزيون في المهجر
لتكون رابطه لهم في الات تحولت الى مكان
عزاء مع الحرب على غزه الدكتور هشام
الدهشان الماني من اصول غزيه يعمل طبيبا
مختصا في جراحه العظام بلغه نبا استشهاد
اغلب افراد عائلته في قصف
اسرائيلي انا للاسف فقد ما يقارب من 90
شخص من افراد عائلتي واغلبهم طبعا نتيجه
القص قصف واكثر الحوادث كانت مؤلمه في قصف
منزل كان فيها حوالي 40 شخص مقيم فراحوا
36 شخص مره واحده يسقط الشهداء في غزه
فتدمع العين وتحزن القلوب في برلين فالم
الفقد عابر للحدود والمسافات يتساوى في
ذلك من هو في الشتات ومن ابى ان يقتلعه
الاحتلال من ارضه الحرب الاسرائيليه على
غزه حسب متابعي في المانيا بعثت وعيا
جديدا بالقضيه الفلسطينيه تجاوز الشرائح
التقليديه ليصل الى فئات جديده من الشباب
والاقليات وحتى من الاسرائيليين المعارضين
لهذه الحرب تحولت بيوت العزاء للعائلات
الفلسطينيه المكلومه في المانيا الى دافع
للكثيرين للخروج الى الشوارع والساحات
لتذكير الساسه الالمان انهم يتحملون جزءا
من معاناه غزه واهلها عيسى طيب الجزيره
برلين